bonjour tout le monde vous venez du Sud
ben bienvenue à Saint-Paul vous avez vu
comment il fait beau à Saint-Paul alors
il faudra en
profiter vous allez emmener les jeunes
officiel et vous allez les évaluer c'est
vous qui allez les noter comme ça à la
fin de la journée soit ils sont jeune
officiels soit ils ne sont pas jeune
officiels c'est vous qui allez les noter
beaucoup d'autonomie aux professeurs
déjà qui gèrent leurs ateliers et aux
élèves parce que bah ils sont dans la
pleine nature c'est les activités qui
sont vraiment spécifiques où on
travaille en équipe toujours minimum
deux trois ou quatre et ils ont donc des
des consignes très simples soit des
consignes de Raider donc où ils vont
participer aux activités soit de
d'officiel
2 1 c'est
par
valable que c'est trop cool j'adore les
courses c'était
bien al en fait faut passer là et
continuer avec l'allonge jusqu'au bout
mais là c'est l'aut côté du oui tu vas y
arriver je sais pas
vous êtes là dans le cas du collège bien
vous appreniez quelque chose qu'est tu
as appris je sais pas trop l'intérêt
bien sûr il est ludique pour ceux qui ne
viennent pas que pour de la compétition
mais il y a pas que du le côté ludique
il y a aussi le le côté
responsabilisation de l'enfant et je
pense que c'est c'est c'est l'un des
objectifs de l'éducation nationale et à
forcerie de l'éducation physique et de
l'UNSS parce qu'ils sont là pour
s'amuser pas pour apprendre
et ben en fait ils vont faire les deux
donc l'objectif de de mon intervention
aujourd'hui c'est de les sensibiliser à
animer des une animation sur autour des
fruits et des légumes dans le cadre
d'une activité sportive qu'est-ce que
vous avez retenu de ce qu'elle a
racontéuse tout tout bah
qui tout oui ben c'est quoi tout il y a
encore du boulot pasl mais en fait ils
sont impressionnés par la caméra mais
ils
savent voilà tient bien alors vous
j'ajitez pas vos armes vous restez bien
vers la
cibleou ben mon rôle c'est c'est le
jeune officier alors on est censé
assurer la sécurité bah de ceux qui
tirent à l'arc ou et bah récupérer les
flèches et faire en sorte B que tout se
déroule bien ça apprend le l'autre côté
de du sport on n'est pas que pratiquant
on peut être aussi organisateur et c'est
ce qui fait que bah plus tard on aura
peut-être des élèves qui seront
organisateurs de trail ou de de raid
dans l'Ouest ou sur l'île de la
Réunion